[Music]
this presentation is about how to get
people who used to book hotels at
booking.com and are not doing anymore
how to get them to come back and work
with us and it's mostly targeting
problem if we don't know who the
churners are we are quite likely to send
information to send emails or to send
incentives to people that would book
otherwise and then we were sort of
wasting money so that's more or less the
business context and at the beginning it
was not so clear at all the ideas
started to develop after a while of
thinking about the problem so today we
can explain the business objective as we
want to use rewards incentives so for
example I offer you 15 euros back if you
make a reservation of at least 100 years
right and the reason we want to do that
is to drive acquisition loyalty or
virality where virality it's an other
sort of program in which you get some
money back if you book and then a friend
of yours books with an incentive that
you send to this person ok a little bit
more of business context at booking PPC
is the pay-per-click is the main
acquisition channel and we think that
it's actually pretty optimized and it's
also expensive and part of the strategy
here is let's try to find out is if
there is some other low-hanging fruit in
which we can get people through to the
website through organic traffic so the
traffic that we generate ourselves with
these incentives that we send to people
ok so the presentation is going to be
mostly about what we have done to create
increased loyalty
and it's mostly for users that we have
information about them
so people whom we have the email and
therefore we can link these two previous
reservations and history of sessions so
let's get started with what is an
incentive campaign so here you have a
few pictures there are different
channels through which we send
incentives the top one is a postcard
that you might receive in your post
postal box the bottom one is the NEEMO
and basically the way we think about
this as data scientist is that in in
these letters we are giving you some
money we are asking you to make a
reservation if you want to get the money
and we require that you spend some
minimal amount there's a channel in
which we send these things it could be
an email it could be a postcard it can
also be shown on the website as a
crawler and there might be other
variables that we want to think about in
order to optimize this channel so for
example how long has it been since you
did the last booking or you were seen on
the website okay so this word the first
attempt so how can we why do we need to
predict who is achernar
so in the first attempts we didn't have
any model to do that we were trying
simple experiments with one variable so
we would choose a variable for example
whether you have been active on the
website in the last X days or not and we
would try to a bit as offering you an
incentive or not doing so right so what
we find out is that as we started having
using variables that were a bit more
sophisticated so that we had a notion
that the variable was correlated with
the user earning so that we had better
targeting the ROI started to improve and
as well if we could add prize
information the ROI started to improve
so here is an
example of one of these first campaigns
fry the email in which you would get
something back if you cook with us
blah blah blah and that's the the result
of the experiment all the gray bars are
here because I cannot show you the the
actual numbers but basically green means
that there was an increase in conversion
that was significant and blue means that
whatever happened it was not significant
and here you have base so the the
problem that we have here is that by
sending these incentives we can actually
increase conversion significantly and
that's what happened on variant 1 and on
variant 3 right but we are cannibalizing
a lot of bookings that would have
happened in any case right and then the
ROI is way below one so at this point is
when we argued like we need to be able
to anticipate who is a earner and send
them incentives according to the
probability of children so this is a
very simple figure to understand the
intuition on why a model would be able
to to help us in this problem so think
of an a/b test again and we are thinking
of net conversion that's the outcome
variable in base we are not offering an
incentive in variant we are so what we
see in base is the amount of conversions
that would have happened if we had done
nothing okay in variant what we see is
what would have happened plus something
else right the problem here is that this
extra amount of conversions that we have
it's not big enough relative to all the
other conversions that we get in order
to have a good ROI or in order to more
than compensate the bookings that we are
cannibalized
so the the model can help us by reducing
as much as possible the blue bar while
keeping as much as possible of the
green area so by learning who is very
unlikely to book we can reduce the
bookings that would have happened in any
case even if we send them incentives and
still get the people who would not book
otherwise so very simple explanation of
of the model so the first attempt we use
information of the last reservation of
the user and about the history of the
reservations and we want to predict
whether they are gonna book or not and
the label that we use here was whether
the person book or not in the next two
years right so we treated the problem as
a classification problem and that is
kind of a pity and that's what Hadi who
is sitting over there we'll talk more
later because we have to sacrifice two
years of data in order to train the
model and also we are not really dealing
well with the problem in the sense that
it's a sensor problem so it might have
been six months since your last
observation but you might be very
unlikely to book again and we want to
use this data but so far this part of
the presentation is that using a
classification algorithm to predict who
is going to talk in this case it was a
random forest and I guess this is
connected yeah
[Music]
nothing so these are the top features
that predict if somebody is going to
turn or not I don't think there is
anything very surprising here so notions
of loyalty
how many bookings have you done with us
so far
also since the last episode of turn so
we can stop we know if a user turn
because we haven't seen him during 2
years but we also know if he came back
or not
so we can also count we can also have a
notion of local loyalty right since the
last episode of churn you might have
come again and booked with us and maybe
you have done 10 more bookings day since
last booking the country of the user and
another notion of the timing between
bookings the AUC of the model that we
use in the experiments was not a
spectacular point 75 but we decided that
even with a simple algorithm we could
probably improve or attempts earlier
with only one variable transposed so
that's the next part of the problem how
can we use the model in an experiment so
the situation here is that now we have a
model gives us a probability of somebody
serving but what we don't know yet is
will these people flip if we offer them
an incentive right and in order if we
had to go with a similar route and try
to predict if somebody's going to flip
whether we offer them an incentive or
not it's going to be time-consuming
because basically we need to start
experiments offering incentives randomly
to people we need to collect the data
train any model and so on so instead we
decided to split the distribution of the
probability of jerk into five pieces so
we use the twentieth 40th and 60th and
80th percentile in order to have five
variants in the experimental
and then we developed hypothesis of how
these people are going to behave so
basically high positive of where are the
flippers and this is a picture where you
can see how the distribution of
probability of churn looks like the blue
line are the ones that are Turner's so
you can see that it separates a bit with
respect to than non Turner's and these
are the hypothesis so the first
percentile those that are very unlikely
to book we expect that we are not going
to find any significant a belief in
conversion and our Y is going to be very
bad because most of these bookends book
would have happen in any case right then
as we move to higher parts of the
distribution cannibalization should
start decreasing these are people who
are less likely to walk so we can get
more important incrementality better ROI
and we expect that at some point along
the distribution we should attack a
significant uplift and have good ROI it
could also be that you know the
significant I believe is somewhere
between 60 and 80 and then it starts
decreasing again because there are
people who are very unlikely to book
with us so there they have really churn
and there's no way to make them come
back ok so again these gray bars are
just to hide the numbers so this is
these are the 5 variants of the
experiment and here we don't see the the
it means BAP is not about incrementality
this is about the conversion that we
observe in vase in each of the av-test
right so here we want to see if first
the model is segregating people well so
these are people who are most likely to
book again these are the ones that have
the highest conversion a little less
likely to book again the bar goes down
and so on so
using the information from base we
learned that okay
the model is putting people in the right
segments and these are the effects on
own incrementality yeah I'm sorry about
this gray is course so these are the
ones that are most likely to book and as
we go down we find the customers who are
less likely to book with us as you can
see there is no significant effect on
conversion in the parts of distributions
that are on the left as we move to the
right of the institution we started
acting significant effects on
incrementality there is a fifth vial
which also look green something
important here variant 2 and variant 3
were offering different amounts of money
but variant one was just contacting
people through email without offering
anything and the effect was almost
significant so we you might interpret
that as actually it's not about offering
them money necessarily it's just about
contacting them at the right time and
these are the effects on the net
commission internet Commission uplift of
each of the other variants and as you
can see basically we are losing money
when we are offering incentives to
people who would have booked very small
effects here and then very big uplift
relative to the other variants in the
experiment the ROI of the two variants
here was way above one all right so this
is the so far the explanation of how we
experimented to try to find a word the
charges are and how to flip them and
today we are working on a framework in
which we can we want to continuously
improve these models maybe developed new
ways of contacting Turner's but still
monitor
whether we are bringing in money or not
so as the models will go full on we want
to be able to continuously test them
I'll go briefly over these lights to
give time to to hurry so basically the
idea here you can think of this as the
experiment that we did right there is a
variant there is various we have a we
define a global blackout group so these
are people who will never receive
incentives and we will always compare
what we are doing with them to know if
we are bringing money or not
in case varying one is better than waste
this model goes full-on so it starts
changing the reality for the users that
we want to target and then if we want to
develop a new model
maybe this model is going to overlap
with some of the people that are
affected by the previous model right so
we are going to do again an a/b test
here to see if this new model can work
but in order to know whether the
previous model that we had and that we
put full on is still bringing in money
regardless of whatever is happening on
top of it so the development of new
models we have a called that group that
is specifically for this for this
attempt so by comparing this yellow area
to the blue area we can know if the
model still bring here money when we add
another one that is overlapping at least
in parts with the segments that are
affected by this one and if the second
model is also successful we put both of
them full-on and we can continue with
this iteration and then we can also ask
the question is is this program overall
bringing and money by comparing
everything that is happening here to the
global blackout group there are two more
slides about this but I'll just leave
the floor for Hadi thank you
okay I'm gonna assure to tell you about
one of our next steps to improve on the
model that we did to predict churners
and that is to go towards survival
models so Ferran told you about the
model that we did to predict churn and
that is we starting from the last
reservation that the user did we create
a window of two years and try to predict
if in that window there is going to be
another booking or not there are some
limitations with this approach as 4/1
mentioned one is that we to create data
for such a classification we have to go
two years back so the latest data that
we have is two years old and the other
limitation that we have is that what if
somebody comes and says hey this two
years is arbitrary what about one year
we have to fit another model six months
another model to whatever another model
and that's not the main challenge even
the main challenge is that once we have
these different models for different
periods what if the results of them are
not consistent with each other so the
one that for two months says yes for I
don't know a few months as now it's
contradictory so survival models are
classic statistical models that handle
this situation and what we use is a very
classic model called Cox proportional
hazards model and so in this case we you
know - in the survival models we usually
have this death event so in our case
sitting from sitting on the last
reservation time point the death event
for us is if another reservation happens
so what we want to predict is the
expected time to the death event which
in this case is expected time for the
next reservation so let's see if we
assume that you know so what these
proportional hazards model generally do
to tell you very shortly is that they
predict they model the hazard and hazard
function hazard is essentially the
conditional likelihood of booking
happening in a time period from now on
given that it has not happened till now
so the proportional hazard model for
model the hazards
as just you know similar to logistic
regression as a sigmoid function of the
features user behavior features as well
as time so here you can see examples of
survival curve so survival curve is a
likelihood of not having died over time
in this case not having made another
reservation over time so you see here
this is one of the user behavioral
features that we have this is number of
bookings in the last 300 days and you
can see that for example the Bay for the
blue curve here you can see that after
this time only a small amount of the
users have not died means most of this
group already booked another time within
this interval so this cares or the
results of the survival model using
using this professional hazard approach
so the way we want to use these models
is that again we want to use the
likelihood return but this time using
the this types of model to incentivize
people and I'm gonna short to tell you
about the idea how do we use that so
take these three users as an example
this is this this line is now and what
we want to do is try to see given the
observation that we have done on these
three users so the user 3 don't his last
reservation just a short time ago user
to evolve back user Yvon avoid back so
sitting now we want to charge instead of
incentivize people who are unlikely to
make reservation from now on within six
months so this is a this is the good
thing that this is the benefit of
survival models these users have
different history they are using the
information you're using this
information that this user has made
history last a servation long time ago
to to free to predict the likelihood
that he is booking so compare it to the
previous approach of our model language
for predicting if from the last
reservation within two years a user
would make a reservation so this was the
previous approach and so the orange
lines for the previous approach and the
green ones they so
the way that we want to use once we have
the likelihood of so this likelihood
both booking in this period so from now
till now plus six months given the
history is exactly the hazard function
and that the to how you see the hazard
function on the survival curves is
exactly that let's say this is a
survival curve of a user and which again
remind you means not having booked again
over time so this the probability of
booking in this period is exactly the
ratio of the survival care value at the
time now plus six months to the survival
care value that's right now
so the intuition behind this is that if
we have a imagine we have a flat curve
and ask in that case means that the user
is unlikely to book in the next six
months compared to someone who we know
they are in the same situation right now
what his survival curve drops sharply
means he is more likely to book in the
next six months so we don't want to we
don't want to incentivize this guy but
we want to incentivize a guy with a more
flat curve hence we use the ratio which
is exactly the price or probability we
use the ratio of s as you see the
survival curve for now for six months to
the servo curve now which is the hazard
function to decide so to send the
incentives or not so here you are seeing
the ratio and here you this is the
distribution somehow of this ratio over
our users so the ones that have a high
ratio means that they're unlikely to
book from Nevada in six months so we
want to incentivize these guys are more
likely to receive incentives and if the
ratio is low obviously these are the
ones who have sharp drop in their
survival curve from now till next six
months so they're less likely to receive
incentives so what we were going to do
is that we're gonna use this approach
and experiment on it right now this is
in process this is in progress but what
we have done so far is that we have put
this approach into a AAA experiment and
what you're seeing here is the
conversion over the buckets of the value
of the hazard function and exocrine see
we are saying we are saying that our
model is sensible in the sense that
conversion is higher
when we predict that the hazard function
is essentially you see that if if this
if this ratio is low so the group that
are the group that very likely to book
we expect to see the convergent for them
as well so that summarizes our next
except to divorce survival models and
with that please thank you very much and
if you have questions any questions I
have a question to the group so called
cannibalization group or this word the
user would would have booked and if you
send intensive you would lost money did
you thought to convert the question that
the user who would have booked but not
receiving incentives that you would lose
the users well we will consider that we
don't lose them because they have booked
recently yeah I'm not sure I understand
exactly how you think about this though
so as far as I understood the user of
would book would not receive incense but
there might be a small population or a
certain population would have actually
considering maybe to leave to switch to
other platform but because they received
incense they would stay so what what we
see actually in the experiment is that
this is not happening at least in a
quantity that is big enough to justify
targeting them because we don't get high
so there are there are actually people
in these groups that if you give them an
incentive will book that's the green
area that you see in the previous graph
so let's say that this is a group in
which cannibalization is high right we
still get some incremental bookings here
but this blue area the ones that are
cannibalized is so big that doesn't
compensate for what we are getting here
so you are right but we don't have today
a way to target these people well enough
to only get this once more questions
yeah thank you for your talk I guess a
lot of for consumers that are not gonna
book again can be predicted a lot of
times right like after one week you may
predict that the same customer it's
gonna turn again or you don't have that
problem I mean you cannot only predict
once if he's gonna turn or not because
it evolves over time so you may predict
that the same customer is gonna turn
after one week or after ten days how do
you handle that so the question is how
do we handle like the time like that the
probability of current changes over time
so one of the things that we do for that
is that we usually limit ourselves to
users whose last observation was a while
back you know to curate some sort of
ways to you know more sensible to target
and if we you know if we are in the
dealing with that group who are very
frequently booking so it's easy to
figure out that we better not interfere
with their happy booking so does that
answer your question I think another
possibility is to basically get
predictions for users with a certain
frequency and see how the probability of
churn that will predict changes over
time this is something that we haven't
done see your question in the back so
thank you for your talk in relation to
the keynote speaker of this morning was
your change in method also influenced by
not being able to keep data for too
is what was the last word sorry sir so
where you're also influenced by GDP are
so maybe a new limit on how long you can
keep personal information so both
approaches haven't been affected by that
the data that we use is anonymize or
encrypted more questions here
maybe final question over there so the
way this this problem was formulated is
in some kind of binary classification
where you are selecting whether a person
is a earner or not and the amount that
you are offering him is set in stone
somehow perhaps the result of an
independent a/b test but could this
problem may be for reformulated into
what is the minimum amount that I have
to offer this guy so that he does not
turn yeah so another next step that is
in development is to predict the right
amount and that we of that we need to
offer to this person and we are we are
thinking of these in in two ways one is
to first offer rewards of different
amount randomly to users to get signal
of what works better for each individual
the other one is for users for whom we
have a lot of history of reservations
mainly use the information of the
previous prices to get an idea of what
is the right reward for them nice I
think it's time to go for a break we'll
be back here at a quarter to four so
let's thank our speakers again
[Applause]